how's it sound if you break something I
can fix it I have a school for young
people who are like you Ching we could
be your new family if you like go
qureishi where is she
she should be dead whatever happened up
there made her stronger she's changing
that's what I'm scared I'm gonna lose
control bad things happen to people like
I'm not giving up on Yugi this is what
family does we take care of each other
so that power destroyed everything that
ever came into contact with until you
what they don't understand they fear
and what they fear we seek to destroy
are you scared little girl who answers
to a man in a chair are you the most
powerful creature on the planet so cool
this is your fault Charles tell me how
we fix this trough tell me what to do
don't know what to do
the girl died she's still Jean which is
still helping sometimes we want to
believe people are something that they
are not whether time you realize who
they are
it's too late
she's coming
x-men Dark Phoenix
you